sorry that's awful i just assume with
that peak perfection of a face that you
must have done a on a surgery oh yeah
well i told you one time about all my
jaw surgery that i had so it took a yeah
it took a lot you told me that you
almost forgot about that right yeah it's
been so long i didn't even know what if
you did an mri scan or something and
you're like they're like do you have any
metal and you're like no no no no i got
nothing well it's like medical stuff so
it's not like i can't stick a magnet to
my face or anything like that it's not
like a plate so it doesn't go flying out
it won't just kill me but i imagine it
ah you ruined my fun little fantasy
whenever i try to get on the you know
the airplane i don't beep whenever i go
through the metal detectors or anything
like that ah come on you ruin it what's
the point
what's the point i can i can bite
properly now stop plexing okay nobody
means how's that flex can you not bite
properly yeah you're flexing your jaw
all right so nine people who took
plastic surgery too far and i would
argue ten because ken you're clearly one
of them
weird it's my bad
making everyone feel bad keep a beard
you know to cover up my
only way to be jealous no one else feels
bad all right let's watch the video
i got this from pop trending okay
yeah fox is a self-proclaimed body
modification artist
have you seen pixie fox no no i haven't
but i have feels i have feelings i'll
wait though all right let's check out
pixie pop hollywood from the movie cool
world she calls herself the living
cartoon she's had a whole host of
surgeries to achieve what she believes
to be total perfection including having
six ribs removed to further accentuate
her curves she wears a tightly bound
corset every day that slims her waist to
a shocking 16 inches she hopes to
achieve my world record for smallest
waist by getting down to around 14
inches very soon that
sounds very dumb i love these workout
clips look i totally work out guys i'm
holding the weight why do they do that
no one that works out poses like that
right working out in heels and
everything you know she's she's serious
about it yeah yeah
there you go that should have been more
of an indicator what is she is she
drinking strawberry milk what is that
it's probably something
frosting thing but just like meal
replacement have you ever looked at like
the the world's smallest waste no like
she's got she's got her work cut out for
her like it's pretty extreme
oh i remember seeing this in guinness
world record book as child wow
where are her intestines is it sad or is
it impressive i don't know
like you can lose you can take your ribs
out you know you can lose body fat but
you can't lose like your
organs internal organs yeah so where do
they go they just get pushed up or
pushed down their legs get squished
that's actually a way she could get the
thinner is if she
like have them outside her body oh
yeah like in a bag or something like a
glass tube or you know
she can talk to you like watch her
digestion that would get her the
thinnest waist wait i wanted to see the
before because they always looked better
before
that's the weirdest part look at that
that's like top model [ __ ] been over 120
thousand dollars on facebook
keep forgetting about it you forget
about the money yeah damn all right
moving on oh yes it's the it's the can
the kendall dude justin jetlika wants to
be the human version of mattel's kindle
and his head over here
which ken doll is there i've never even
seen that kendall
this is the keanu reeves kendall what is
this
[Laughter]
am i wrong for assuming he has like
chest implants he's got a lot of
different implants i've i've seen you've
seen a lot about these people yeah i've
seen a lot about these people he's got
like shoulder implants back implants
implants he's implanted he says his
ultimate goal is to one day become one
hundred percent plastic justin's
extensive list of surgeries include five
nose jobs and augmentations to his
cheeks lips buttocks and chin oh god the
muscle implants man that's gotta stop
like you could reach this physique at
the age right stop stop this [ __ ] man
just get hire a professional trainer
instead of all that money like damn how
much you're trying to avoid we're just
working out man
the hardest part is getting into the gym
you know it's tough it's easier to get
into the surgery room are you kidding me
no well you get to sleep and you wake up
and you look better it's easy you know
oh you think this looks good all right
interesting his triceps biceps and even
his chest are all silicone implants oh
my god
to all his muscles all over there
someone asked hey can you bring in the
groceries it's like no i can't do it so
here's a question for you when you
exercise do you exercise so you can be
stronger and more fit or do you exercise
because you want to look good and take
instagram pictures well not to be well
that's strong as a bonus absolutely but
i want to look good you make you want to
look good right so yeah yeah he wants to
look good too so he's just paying for it
instead of
you know using his time and effort well
i think just any kind of shortcut kind
of misses the whole point it's not just
about
looking good it's the journey that you
take to get there otherwise it's
meaningless
it says who says who says i have my own
philosophy on it yeah every single
person that looks at like a fad diet and
goes
i want to do that they're not looking at
the journey to get there that's why all
the diets fail they're looking at the
end results that's why i'm still fat
if i don't carry anything about that
journey i just want to lose the weight
and eat my feet
you're gonna gain the weight again if
you have a bad mindset i know it's sad
part of it i'm right
i'm fry come on edgar how many times do
i have to tell you use nordvpn i don't
care if you're crying unless you use
nordvpn your data won't stay safe behind
the wall of next level encryption
no listen you listen to the ad there's a
strict no logs policy they don't track
collect or share anything all your
secrets are saving all your secrets
gain access worldwide you like anime
right you can watch in japan you get
instant secure access to hundreds of
streaming service websites online you
get worldwide access enjoy instantly
streaming to hundreds of services online
with a simple click you're connected you
can use it on your computer on your
phone and you're allowed to connect up
to six devices
and if you sign up right now using the
link in the description nordvpn.com
pewdiepie you get a huge discount but
you also get one additional month for
free bonus which is a great deal so take
advantage of that by using the link in
the description i use nordvpn to make
sure if i want to be extra safe like
doing online banking especially if
you're using a public network that's a
must i think in general using public
networks i always use a vpn just to make
sure i'm safe but also it's great to
connect to other countries if you want
to stream you know you know you know
what i don't need to say anymore but you
know
i recommend it i use it all the time
it's great use the link in the
description to sign up today they also
have nord pass which you should be using
it's a password manager if you don't
have a password manager i don't know
what to tell you but you should have one
okay thank you nervy pan get on with the
video edgar i'm sorry i love you during
one surgery he risked the chance of
going blind as he wanted to remove some
unsightly forehead veins the surgery had
to be performed through his eyelids and
the tool used to burn the veins came
dangerously close to his retinas the 35
year old has had over 190 different
worth it but you can tell like even like
top surgeons to that quarter of a
million you can tell like those are not
real muscle i'm not even really too sure
if it's about the look anymore
more about the attention because this
guy's like on
all the tv shows everything anything
anybody talks about plastic surgery
bro new york city social life jocelyn
wildenstein was afraid that her
billionaire husband would leave her if
she looked too old so
well
how old is she bro just age please it's
more beautiful age natural about 40
million
plastic surgery to alter her appearance
let's go
known as the manhattan cat lady she's
had her face pulled back so much that
the placement of her eyes have been
permanently altered she wanted to do
this what is happening it keeps going
what the hell is this
she became caveman
that is sad dude that is a sad thing to
look at it is what is that show
animorphs oh i feel bad it's still a
person they just want to look pretty but
man oh man oh man she wasn't worried
that her billionaire husband would leave
her like i guess she sounded pretty
neptune was like well
stretch my face to the extreme here we
go this is this is the bogan of brothers
right here the legends
the legends who are they yeah that's a
good question who are these people well
i need to find out now science fiction
producers yeah they look straight out of
a sci-fi oh they're also what does it
say their prey is cryptocurrency
investors wait
hang on a second i got some bitcoin bro
don't even are they coming after me are
they gonna eat me in 1997 oh my god she
was she was pretty her husband having
sex with a 19 year old russian model and
they soon developed no no that's not her
that's the russian model
oh
in the divorce settlement and 100
million dollars a year in alimony now
what what is that what is that why
i i have a child let's say hypothetical
child
18 they're 18. sayonara [ __ ] i
don't know
right
[Laughter]
okay yeah
why if i have a wife i gotta pay a
hundred million a year who needs that
right to pay for their child
this is the biggest scam of history
right here ladies and gentlemen okay
well i think i think let me play let me
just argue the other side i guess no
there's nothing
but go ahead and try it if they were if
they were still together and you know
all the money was in the same place then
that child would have the benefit of his
life from that money and so they don't
want to lose that right maybe that's the
boo-hoo
what the [ __ ] is that
hey look you got all that money you can
afford to wrap it up okay you don't even
have no kids if you can't pay for them
there's got to be a limit man there's
got to be a limit no one needs 100
million a year that's in alimony no one
i don't know she got 2.5 billion from
the divorce then why would she even like
get this to herself to begin with
just take the divorce and be like all
right cool well i'll see you later
forever too yoku became obsessed with
having smooth skin at the age of 28 she
had silicone injected into her face to
supposedly smooth out her wrinkles over
the coming years she would inject more
and more to the point that her face
became puffy and inflamed at one point
doctors refused to perform any more
injections on her in her desperate
attempt to look you know
oh my god ah
why is it always that far what the [ __ ]
are these doctors doing they're like oh
no i'm not going to do it anymore
because it's too far i'm like you should
have stopped like 600 surgeries ago what
are you doing that's that's exactly what
i was about to say before like it
like leather face from the texas
chainsaw massacre showed up like there's
a lot of a lot of these people everybody
on here i imagine like their surgeons
would be like hey go see the
psychiatrist first or this therapist oh
my god i can see me but no it's just
like holy crap that's sad that sucks
doctors are part of the problem here and
i don't think that's an acknowledged in
a lot of ways they put it on them right
i've had 42 surgeries and i look like a
cat lady and it's like who's doing the
surgery yeah
who keeps doing this to you holy [ __ ]
they're like abusing mentally ill
patients that's a twist that's a way to
look at it
yeah yeah doctor's supposed to help
people huh anyway maybe this is helping
them maybe this is helping them now
i can guarantee you it isn't
and on nice note love yourself for the
way you are you are perfect you are
beautiful yeah i thought about i thought
about getting like a hair transplant one
time i told you right like yeah
but i mean i kind of i kind of like it
now i think it looks
it's not bad i've never noticed anything
i think your hair looks great i mean i'm
not the elon musk or anything over here
man he needed that hair
did worse for him
anytime i look at it i'm like oh maybe
yeah
maybe i too could be super rich if i
just get my hair dead you know
or you just face i said go full on
that's true
he accepted the lex luthor yeah yeah
well if you enjoyed this video smash
like and subscribe and remember check
out ken's channel we make videos over
there as well and that's it bye